i am nick gillespie with my co author of
the Declaration of Independence how
libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America Matt Welch our next
question comes from lack Gong lap Gong
Liang what do you think about fiscal
conservatives who are also social
conservatives right slap PS it is not an
oxymoron and what I think about them is
that I wish that they would agree with
me more about social conservatism no
more seriously I'm happy to have an ally
on any issue part of what our book talks
about is that the future of politics
belongs less to broad political
groupings and more to single issue
swarms people who believe for instance
that right now we are out of money at
every single level of government and
that we need to urgently cut the size of
government right now a lot of fiscal
conservatives who were also social
conservatives are great on that issue
and I'm glad that they are great on that
issue and I can work with them on it and
meanwhile there's going to be plenty of
people who are not fiscal conservatives
who are going to be great on things like
the drug war so I'm happy to have allies
I don't expect everyone to agree with me
about everything I think it's important
to remember that libertarianism is a
political philosophy it's not nestled in
our lives I welcome social conservatives
who are in favor of limiting the power
of the state and transferring more power
to voluntary associations whether they
are community groups religious groups
business groups whatever so come on
aboard social cons you have nothing to
lose but your irrelevance to political
debates